today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind the anti-procrastination
sipper if you want that small upper
you can get it go to magicmind.co
and use code theo magic for 20
off today's guest um
is his second time returning to the
podcast he has a new book out
beyond order 12 more rules
for life i am uh i'm almost to rule
number four
right now and um and man he's just uh
you know i'm gracious for his time you
know i'm honored to be able to talk to a
thinking man this man is a real thinker
and
and an order and sometimes i can think
and sometimes i can talk but
rarely can i do both uh he's a professor
he's high level
in so many fields he's a
best-selling author sold over 5 million
copies
of his first book 12 rules for life
um ladies and gentlemen mr
jordan peterson
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Applause]
just
dr peterson great to see you again hi
theo it's really good to see you too
it's been a while a long while
yeah it has been a while thank you uh
for the new rules i gotta ask you how
many
how many more rules are there overall
because it's starting to add up
well originally there was a list of 42
i published that on quora i've heard
that
yes and so in principle there's 18 more
but of course you know there's an
infinite number of necessary rules
um i don't think i'll publish any more
rule books however
uh yeah i'm just letting you know as a
as someone who's trying to abide by the
rules we're
doing our best out here and we're glad
that there's more but it's also it's a
lot it's a lot to do you know it's a lot
yeah yeah well and and you can only beat
the same horse so many times
yeah i don't think that's actually a
saying but now i've invented it
well i've seen so i grew up in some
areas they had a little bit of mild
animal cruelty by us growing up nothing
real heavy but you know uh
probably i'm glad some of it wasn't
documented at the time actually
um so i i tried to get as far as i could
in into a beyond order into the new book
and um and it's just you know it's hard
there's a lot of like
you have to you have to take your time
and you have to really absorb as you go
and um there was one part there's a lot
of parts that stuck out for me but
so far there's a part in uh chapter
three
um where you talk about fear and you
talk about the fog
and um and i i wrote down a sentence
that says that sometimes you're so
afraid
that you will not allow yourself to even
know what you want
uh i think that's very common it really
hit me hard because
sometimes i you know i admit i'm afraid
to like
i'm afraid to even map out even to
really write down and map
out what i want um but i don't know
exactly i tried to really drop down and
figure out what the fear was like why am
i afraid like
and and i had some i've had some trouble
really figuring that out like
am i afraid that i'll have to then do it
am i afraid that i'll then
feel inadequate based upon what i really
want and where i currently
am um so i just wanted to
you to maybe expound on that a little
bit and and just kind of share like
what did you think why do i get afraid
to to really
admit even admit to myself what i really
want
well i think you put your finger on two
um of the fundamental reasons
um if you don't allow yourself to know
what you want then you haven't
established
your conditions for failure right i mean
if you
if you're aiming at a goal and
the goal is really clear then
you can sorry i lost you
oh you did yes
just visually or can you still hear me i
i can hear you just okay there we go
sorry about that
no worries okay you're better than just
being still too someone might get a
little no it was it was
absolute blood pressure minimized okay
let's forget about that we can go back
to this
okay um if you know what you want
then you know when you're failing
if you don't allow yourself to know what
you want you can keep that foggy
if you don't set out the conditions for
your success then you can avoid your
responsibility because
again that's not clear and the problem
with wanting something is that in all
probability you're going to have to work
for it you're going to have to make
sacrifices and
it's certainly possible that you want to
avoid that
you you might be afraid to make it clear
because
other people could deny it to you too
which is something i write about a fair
bit in that chapter
um the problem is and and
failing to make any of that clear
protects you right now
but it's really hard on you over the
medium to long term
because if you don't make it clear to
yourself what you want
or to other people the probability that
you're just going to stumble into it is
pretty low
and and you can put that off
indefinitely day after day but
the problem with that is that you age
while you're doing that and
there's obviously a price to be paid for
that
so that chapter that's chapter three do
not hide things in the fog
[Music]
i mean it's a it's a warning about
failing to pay attention
you know knowledge emerges in a very
strange way it it emerges
obviously when we learn something we
started out by not knowing it and so
what that means is that knowledge goes
through a transformation process from
being
absolutely not there to being explicit
and fully
detailed and one step of that process is
emotion
and so for example you might find
yourself frustrated disappointed
about the events of the day but be
unable to exactly specify
why that's extremely common you know you
go home to your partner and
you be in a bad mood and you know you'll
snap at them for something and they'll
say well what's up with you and
you'll say well nothing you're just
being annoying when it's perfectly clear
to both of you that there is actually
something up with
you and then that disappointment and
frustration
anger and sadness let's say or anxiety
is a sign that something isn't right
but it isn't like it isn't necessarily
that you're repressing knowledge of
what's not right it's that you just
you actually don't know and the emotion
is the first
step in the process by which that
knowledge emerges
and you might have to sit and think and
talk
to your partner to a friend for god only
knows how long before you're actually
going to put your finger on
what it is that you're upset about and
it could be
very far removed from whatever happened
to trigger you in the moment
and so that's the fog and you can keep
things in the fog just by
not doing that it's really easy it's no
dif more difficult than just sitting
there doing nothing
because creating knowledge is active and
difficult
yeah well it's you know we've crea and
we've created
such a perfect fog these days like
really the fog has been
it's become such a the fog is such a
business every little thing that they
can
that can be created to take away your
attention
from uh or that can take away our
attention from figuring out who we are
or like kind of spelunking inside of
ourselves and trying to get some answers
um has really been created it's almost
it's pretty masterful how much has been
created
out here on the outside to keep our
attention um
away from delving inside of ourselves
well you know
attention is the basic currency right
everyone
fights for it and it's incredibly
valuable
and it it certainly is the case that
it's also very tempting to turn your
attention to
things that grasp your short-term
interest
rather than say pursuing the causes of
negative emotion that's a
that's a good example and of course we
have massive corporations working night
and day to
continually attract our attention and
there's something sinister about that
obviously but but you can't exactly lay
responsibility at their feet because
there isn't that there's a tremendous
overlap between
educating people informing them and
and making them attend to you and and
the lines between all of those things
are very foggy let's say and difficult
to
lay out it's certainly the case that one
of the ways that you can keep yourself
in a fog
about yourself is by distracting
is through distraction with external uh
with anything in the external world and
obviously computer technology cell
phones games
well not negative in and of themselves
perhaps
are there at any moment to distract you
at any moment yeah those
yeah the little things that are time
consumers like it's yeah there's
companies there are businesses where
that
is their that's their that's their
business is to get your attention
everything's trying to get our attention
sometimes i worry
that the forces that are out there that
have like started to
you know really create algorithms even
on how to get our attention and how to
keep it
that those forces are stronger than
our human abilities to to keep them away
from us
do you feel like that that's true or do
you feel like that that's just
i really do believe that that's true i
look
as far as i can tell we are teaching
computers to
to read our minds as fast as we possibly
can
and they're way better at it than they
were 10 years ago and they're going to
be so much better at it in five years
that we won't even be able to imagine it
and
when i say read our minds i'm not
talking about something
magical but oh yeah for example not
talking about like guess what
it's not like like they're gonna guess
what we're thinking or guess what we
want for dinner or anything like that
probably
well they might but they won't do it by
directly reading our brain waves or
anything like that
um they'll they're already algorithms
that target advertisements to send that
you are pretty good at
deciding what it is that you're
motivated to pursue and
now i heard i actually just got an ad on
my phone for your new book actually so
yeah oh well good so i'm involved in the
same process the same nefarious process
i'll just joke that that i think it's
facebook
but i might be wrong about this that
owns oculus
and the headset the vr headset company
now
you can you can track eye movements
with uh vr headset and psychologists
use the tracking of eye movements to map
attention in high detail now look
if you look at our eyes you see that
there's a colored circle and a dark
circle in the middle and then that's
surrounded by
white and that makes your eye very
visible
to other people animals too but to other
people particularly
human eyes are quite unique in that
regard and
it looks like we've evolved to have
highly visible eyes
and the reason for that is that other we
communicate
with other people and they can read our
motivations by watching our eyes
so if you stand in the corner and you
look up
at nothing in the sky and you stand
there long enough
someone else will join you and then if
there's two people then they'll be ten
right away and the reason for that is
that
we and this is again something uniquely
human
we attend to where other people point
their eyes
assuming that if they're interested in
we might be interested in it too
and so that's and human beings are
visual animals about half our brain is
is taken up with visual processing we're
much more visual than virtually any
other animal
and so computers are soon going to be
able to track where we place our eyes
which of course advertisers are
incredibly interested in
and that's going to speed up the ability
of
of high-powered computational devices to
understand
human beings as a group but also each of
us individually to an immense degree
an immense degree and so and i
i think we're probably 10 years away
from computers that understand us better
than we understand ourselves
ai machines are going to get extremely
good at this because it's so
lucrative to to be able to gauge
attention there's there's nothing that's
more valuable than that
and so do you feel like it sh do you
feel like
there should be le it's hard to say
there should be legislation because
i hate to put anything on the uh you
know that the gov it's the government's
responsibility
but should there be like rules or
legislation
between allowing computers and ai to get
that advanced or is it still just fall
on the
feet of us as humans just to battle kind
of the dark arts of
of of these machines that can sort of
like take us into a trance and then
monetize the trance at the same time
i think i think that legislation in some
sense is
it's going to be playing catch-up and
it's going to be farther and farther
behind all the time
because this is moving so fast and with
such power
and it's so distributed that no one is
going to be able to
even keep track of it much less
regulated i mean
the the the the interconnected
environment is
changing so rapidly that even if you're
reasonably
tech savvy you can't keep up with all
the major changes
and there's there's no evidence
whatsoever that that's going to do
anything but accelerate
and so i can't see how legislators have
the ghost of a chance at keeping up
with this even if they knew what to
target or what to legislate
yeah and you know more and more
engineers are i think china now
graduates more engineers every year than
the united states has
engineers oh yeah china you could be
eight years old in china and be a damn
engineer i've been over there and i've
seen it
but i've seen a six-year-old build a
damn bridge in front of me you know what
i'm saying they
they're highly capable yes well and lots
of other
cultures are coming online very rapidly
and so
we're well and there's no shortage of
unbelievably proficient amateurs online
as well and
and and programming and and so
we ain't seen nothing yet and i really
do believe computers are gonna
your computer is gonna understand you so
well i think it
it won't be long till it knows what
you're going to do
more accurately than you do i think
that's already true to some degree
but well then we're at a real loss
because then if i've been afraid to make
a plan for myself in my life
and i've been afraid and i've been
living in the fog and i've been just
you know kind of sidestepping
really putting my [ __ ] pants on as a
human
and taking some action if i'm in that
fog
and then the computer is able to figure
out what i'm gonna do
before i've even done it but i haven't
even made a plan then surely the
computer's going to make a plan for me
it feels like
i think the computer is making a plan
for you all the time already
by default look that's exactly what
advertising is
is advertising makes a plan for you it's
there's no difference between those two
things except maybe one of
sophistication
so you know i mean when you're watching
something and an ad pops up
that's a little world that you could
visit and
the advertiser obviously wants you to
visit that and the the problem there
because you might think well it would be
really good the computer can help you
make a plan but i think what's more
likely to happen
because at least to begin with the
computer is going to be paid so to speak
by the advertisers to
capitalize on your short-term
impulsivity is that
ever more attractive distractions are
going to be
dangled in front of you and that's
and that that's likely to keep you in
the fog
and and what can i do to battle the fog
like what can i do
you know as a human to retain
my humanity as things get
more tech and more
and and as tech becomes far smarter
in some ways you know in in technical
ways than i'll ever be
well you know i wish i knew the answer
to that
uh i don't partly because
the the landscape that's unfolding in
front of us
because it changes so rapidly it's
unpredictable um
you know other rules in in my two books
address that to some degree i think
your your best bet the best bet you have
virtually all the time is to try
not to lie to yourself in in my first
book
um 12 rules for life i said do not lie
or
no i said the rule was tell the truth or
at least do not lie
because you know you might i mean
can you tell the truth you'd have to
know the truth you know you might be
able to tell some partial truths
but you can't tell the truth but you can
not say things that you know to be false
and
in the second book the new one rule five
is
do not do things that you hate which is
also a kind of lie
and and i don't mean um don't do
difficult things like get out of bed at
six in the morning and exercise you know
you might say well i hate going to the
gym and
that isn't what i you don't really hate
going to the gym you just find it
difficult um
i'm thinking more that you might observe
yourself engaging in activities
that you find despicable even right then
but certainly later when your conscience
dwells on them and
that you should stop doing that because
that's a form of behavioral lie
i think the only thing we have to orient
ourselves is
as individuals is our willingness to
to live to live a life that's relatively
free of
of unnecessary deceit or of deceit at
all
the 11th rule is do not allow yourself
to become deceitful resentful or
arrogant i might have those
out of order but it's concentrating on
the same
sort of idea you know it's partly
here's another way of looking at it your
your attention moves around for reasons
that you don't quite understand
those reasons are unconscious um
you can tell that to some degree because
you can't make yourself pay attention to
something that you
aren't interested in well you can but
you really have to work at it you know
it's really easy to
pay attention to something you're
interested in
that's not difficult at all in fact it's
enjoyable whereas
paying attention to something that
you're not interested in requires will
and effort
and and so you can see that there's
unconscious mechanisms at work there
because you can't control
them now the danger to deceit
is that you'll pathologize those
unconscious mechanisms
because as you practice something
imagine you practice a particular form
of untruth you tell yourself a story
that you know to be false
and that becomes your habitual way of
looking at the world
well what that means is that you're
forming habits that are unconscious
because habits become unconscious
and then they skew the way the world
appears to you it'll
it'll pull your interest in places that
that aren't good for you to go that
aren't associated with
the real world and so that's not to be
wished for that's because you
you don't want to be out of sync with
your automatic self that's
that's bad news and lying definitely
does that especially if it's habitual
so because it creates whatever is truth
well it creates a false truth and a
false you
right you know because there's different
kinds of memory there's the memory
that's associated with
the way the world is and that's called
episodic memory
and then there's another or declare or
declarative memory there's another kind
of memory
that's memory for action and so
that's what you use when you play tennis
or ride a bike or play the piano
you know how to move your hands and you
move your body and
that's a kind of a kind of memory as
well and
you don't want to pathologize either of
those
um because then you become you see once
once the deceit has become habitual then
you're it's victim you're its pawn
because it's automatic and that's a
that's a terrible
fate you don't want that you don't you
really don't want that
i think your best defense against
anything that's trying to
hijack your attention is is something
like honesty
it's also very useful and i stress this
quite a bit in this second book
to surround yourself with people who
want the best for you and who care for
you because they can also help
keep you on the straight and narrow path
and you know that's not a matter of some
trivial
moral injunction it's there's terrible
places you can end up
oh yeah oh yes i've been to some of
those places and it's
yeah and you don't get any sleep when
you're there either i'll tell you that
um right right another indication that
your unconscious mind is
is not working properly at some point
right because the sleep wake cycle gets
gets uh dysregulated that's very
unpleasant to say the least
dr peterson so when i so getting back
like to the fog and like
and like and just the the things that
can take away our attention and how
valuable our attention is
what can i do like to kind of
are we going to start to see like new
parts of like new
like small societies form of people that
don't want to be influenced by
technology
or you know what do you what do you feel
like
some of the future looks like as far as
trying to retain
some sense of of holding on to
my attention and using it for myself
as opposed to letting it be used by
outside influences
does that make any sense or not yes yes
well
look there's another rule i suppose a
dictum perhaps
that if you don't have your own story
then you're going to be a bit player in
someone else's story
okay so let's talk about that fog again
so
let's say because of the reasons you
already laid out
you don't want to make your conditions
for failure conscious because then you
know when you're failing and that hurts
you don't want to make your plans for
the future too clear because
then if you then if you don't attain
what you're looking for it's very clear
that you've lost it which is somewhat
different than failure right
and then there's also the problem that
if you make your motives clear to other
people
then they really have the ammunition to
hurt you because
like i can hurt you by depriving you of
what you want
but i can hurt you even better if i
really know what you want and can
deprive you of that so you have reasons
to keep these things unclear
but then and then you but the problem
then is is that you don't have a
a direction that's powerful right
because you're not consulting yourself
watching yourself
learning about yourself figuring out who
you are and figuring out
what kind of route through life you
would have to take to be engaged okay so
then you get weak
because you're not integrated you're all
over the place you're scattered
um well then anybody who
is has power for one reason or another
or can
compete with you for your own attention
and win and so if you don't have your
own plan
painful as it is to develop one partly
because you have to take your own
inadequacies into account
oh yes and you also mentioned you know
you you posit an ideal this is what i
want or this is who i could be
the farther away that is from you the
more inadequate you feel in relationship
to it you know so that's another reason
to avoid it but
yes well that's why every ideal is a
judge
there's no getting away from that now if
it's too much for you
i might say well make a lesser ideal
like try to pursue something that
doesn't intimidate you into paralysis
right start with something closer that's
more manageable huh so you can even
prove to yourself that you can do it
exactly well what you really want to do
is you want to lay out a
a plan that has a pretty high
end aim but that also consists of steps
that aren't too intimidating that that
so you have to ask yourself um i would
like to do this
um i should do it but would i do it
and the answer is likely to be no often
because you know what you're like you're
supposed to go to the gym but you don't
it's like okay well maybe you won't go
to the gym but maybe you'd walk
half a block every second day something
like that and you have to ask yourself
i write about this in the first chapter
about the advantage of being a fool
you know if you notice that you're not
so good at something then you can
calibrate down the goal until a fool
like you can manage it
and then you can attain it and then
you're not quite so much of a fool
and so okay so you have to build a plan
i have a
tool for that that i often recommend for
people called self-authoring
yeah yeah yeah i'm very familiar with it
okay well
and it is it it was developed in an
attempt to help people
write out well an account of themselves
past present and future but
relevant to this discussion is to to
make a plan it's like
what is it that you need to thrive in
the world or at least not to become
bitter and if you don't have your own
plan that you're committed to
right and honestly committed to what
that means is that you will be the pawn
of other people's decisions especially
now more than ever it feels like do you
think that that's true well that's
that's that certainly seems to be
the conclusion we're reaching in the
course of this conversation it's like as
the
powers around you become more and more
invasive
but also also of more utility to you to
some degree i mean we don't want to be
completely negative about computational
power right
as the forces around you have more and
more capacity to
grip your attention it stands to reason
that you're going to have to
be the captain of your own ship to a
greater and greater degree
otherwise you'll fall
you'll fall prey to those who wish to
monetize your attention
so it's time for it's time to make a
plan if you haven't made a plan it's
time to have a plan it's a really
it's a really good time to have a goal
and to have a plan
yes yes i think i think that's it's
always been the case that it's been good
to have a plan but
you know i think it's particularly the
case when things are changing so rapidly
around you too
you know because then it's your own ship
you have place for you
in in this maelstrom of constantly
transforming opportunities and
possibilities
i do think it seems to me that
we're increasingly being called upon to
act as
independent moral agents now you know
informed by tradition
obviously because it's very difficult to
become wise all on your own
but but and i suppose it's partly
because we have more possibility and
more power so we have to take more
responsibility
i i can't see a way out of that right
yeah i think that makes sense i mean and
it's hard if we if we
think about our own story it's scary to
make ourselves the hero of our own story
in a lot of ways it feels
i mean it feels like what we would want
to do but it feels scary because you see
what a hero has to do
you know yes what he is presumptuous
doesn't it
you know like who are you to be a hero
well
you know we used to maybe now it feels
like it's a necessity almost though a
little bit more it starts to feel like
it's becoming more of a necessity that
if i want to really get through this
and not only get through it but do it
well and be a leader
and be someone who can affect others and
be positive and be a part of
what's good then i need to
at some point admit that maybe i do want
to be my own hero
you know yes well and i also think you
have to deeply consider the alternatives
you know it's so as a clinician i
frequently
saw that my clients were afraid to make
a move
um i talked about that a little bit oh
yeah i think it's in that's in chapter
five again do not do what you hate which
is
full of sort of practical advice i
suppose in relationship to career
people are often afraid to make a change
to make a plan to make a decision to
take responsibility
and the right response to that is yes
no wonder you're afraid it's not this is
frightening
people you know they they want to get a
new job so they have to
um they have to form format and update
their
their cvs their resumes well just that
alone is
is enough to stop many many people
cold because first of all
you have to gather up all that
information and then second you have to
make a coherent narrative account of
your life and third you have to face all
the things that you did in the past
that didn't work out the way they were
supposed to you have to take account of
the gaps in your
in your resume like to make a resume is
to take a cold hard look at yourself
it's like oh
god who the hell wants to do that like
an inventory kind of
yes exactly and but but and so you're
afraid of that and you put it off and
you put it off
oh yeah and you you can't say well don't
be afraid of that
what you can say i think that's more
useful is okay
you don't like your job you don't like
your current position you don't like
your status you don't like your income
you don't like your trajectory
that's why you want to change okay well
let's say you don't
make your resume then what does the
world look like in five years
like frightening as it is to make a plan
um
unhappy stasis just disintegrates
right and so one of the things we do do
in the self-authoring program in the
future authoring
program is say well um if you
deteriorated according to your own vices
and that went that got out of hand what
would that look like
five years down the road you know
everyone knows
some people some people flirt with with
alcoholism or drug abuse or um
or uh sex addiction
yes yes yes that's right fractured
relationships
even candy whatever and then you know
you have a sense in your mind of what
you'd be like if you let yourself
go oh well i'd be sick man i'd be under
a bridge or something i'd probably be
behind like a
i don't know living behind a tim hortons
or something you know some type of place
i'm trying to make it local to you but
like some yeah i'd be living you know
i'd just be doing drugs or just
probably listening to aerosmith i'd be
outdoors i bet no real home
i'd have no fear so for you so it's for
you it's a vision of homelessness and
and substance abuse yeah yeah well you
gotta ask yourself like okay
think about that is that what you want
and i don't i mean
think about it imagine that that's what
awaits you
well then you have a better thing to be
afraid of
it's like afraid as i am of of
gripping my own destiny here's the
alternative right
now you've created the now you've
created a reality of what that looks
like so now you have something to battle
against right
yes exactly right you need part of
part of being motivated is to be afraid
of the proper things
you know afraid as you might be of
success and fair enough
it's possible that you should be more
afraid of stagnation and failure
but you have to make those things real
for you before they have any power
yeah as you're talking i'm even
realizing that if i don't make the
the the lowest if i don't make the
reality of what could happen if i don't
take care of myself and if i were to
like devolve and disintegrate into my
worst
place if i don't make that a reality it
almost
lets me stay in the fog even more
because
now even the there's not even the the
end hasn't even been created i've left
it all just so
vague that i can just kind of meander
around it's like um
it it reminds me a little bit i didn't
want to quit smoking for a while because
if i quit smoking then i would have to
actually
then do something else good for myself
or i would have to then
be a non-smoker and a non-smoker might
then go for a run
or he might like you know uh
then achieve a different goal so one of
the reasons i realized for a while that
i didn't quit smoking was because
if i was real honest with myself i
wanted to always have an excuse
of why i couldn't do other stuff right
i think that's a really good that's the
kind of observation that's necessary
so you've made three observations so far
about you know
sort of nefarious dark motives that keep
you down
you said well there's the unwillingness
to take responsibility
um the the fear of the distance between
you and your ideal and then now you had
another one which is well
it isn't just quitting smoking because
that's part of the decision to be
healthier
well what does that mean well it doesn't
just mean quit smoking it implies other
things
and and those things are effortful in
the moment
right they pay off in the medium to long
term but they're effortful in the moment
and so and it it
that your ability to do that is
exactly part and parcel of that process
of pulling things out of the fog it's
like
and these are really good questions to
ask yourself it's like well what
what reasons do i have that i don't want
to admit
that they're stopping me from doing
those things that i want to or know that
i should
i'm afraid of judgment mostly usually
afraid of judgment
yeah yes yes i'm afraid i'll fail
uh i'm afraid i'll realize that i'm not
good enough or i was never capable
enough in the first place
right that's a really big one right
there it's like um
i watched this simpsons episode recently
where bart had to get a c
on one class or or be held back
and he actually studied for like two
days and then he failed
and he broke down and he said well my
god this is so terrible because i was
failing before but
i wasn't trying and so i could always it
wasn't really failure
because i never tried i never tried but
this time i really tried and yet
i failed and well it turns out that
you know it works out for him in the end
but that's not the point i thought
it was a very apropos episode because
it is much different to fail when you've
gone all in you know and that's
that's very frightening where does that
fear come from inside of us is that a
fear that's just built into like
it's part of the human journey as a
human
it's part of the journey of the spirit
um
is that something that's just built into
us
from birth kind of or do you think that
some of that fear is learned over time
what do you what do you think about that
well i think i think fear of failure is
part and parcel of
of being human um
the particulars of that can be changed a
lot by
by uh by your upbringing i mean if you
were punished unduly for failure
or perhaps protected too much from it so
you have no
uh experience with it then that can
certainly
elevate the danger your own temperament
can do that too because
you know sometimes some people are more
prone to catastrophize
as a consequence of relatively trivial
failures and that can bring them down
so but we are future oriented creatures
and
that's a deep part of our nature and so
that fear of
failure fear of judgment all the things
that you've
raised so far um
are are there deeply central to our
nature
so you also mentioned you know we talked
a little bit earlier about how
not clarifying your future goals
can keep you in the fog you pointed out
you can do that equally with
the future that is the failure and
i think that's equally true is by
you know you're smoking and
you cannot think about that it's quite
easy to not think about it'll plague you
now and then but
to think about something generally
speaking is effortful and often you also
have to talk to other people and so
you have to put some time and energy
into it
whereas not thinking about something is
pretty easy and so
you'll be you know you wake up in the
morning and cough and
feel terrible because you smoked way too
much and if you
thought about that for a little while
you could see quite quickly where that's
probably leading
but you can just not do that distract
yourself think about something else
um oh yeah think about it yep play a
game
think about a puzzle think about a
friend think about it yeah do there's so
many
things you could do so then you leave
yourself undefined well
the problem with all of that too is that
i think
then in some sense you you're destined
to fail
in the most fundamental sense because
unless you believe that you can get what
you want
without being sophisticated about
failure and being sophisticated about
success and
i don't believe that because being
successful at anything
is actually rather unlikely although
being successful at something
you have a decent shot at but any
particular thing is quite unlikely
and then if you put obstacles in your
path well
and you're facing competition because
you're
definitely always facing competition
yeah there's people that want to define
themselves there's people that want to
make that effort that want to you know
like
open their eyes in the fog and really
try and see themselves you know
um yeah that's gonna be competition
yes and in all likelihood they're going
to get there before you
unless unless you think that you can
stumble fortunately into what you desire
and i don't think
virtually no one believes that if pushed
you know they might
assume that in some ways and act like
that in some ways but if you push
someone and say look you know
if you tried harder would you do better
they think well
yeah probably yeah and so
it's hard to deceive yourself about such
things is it more of a western
kind of philosophy that we can
like the fog is almost uh is it more of
a
um luxury almost of western civilization
to even be able to have a fog
i feel like in some cultures and
societies
a fog would be a luxury maybe because
you have to face
real elements of survival more often
well we could say maybe that it's a a
danger
of right in a better way right right
well i've wondered this you know
so let's say you're a parent and you're
reasonably well off
well how much do you do for your kids
and the answer to that is surprisingly
complicated
because on the one hand you want to do
everything you can
on the other hand if you deprive them of
necessity
then you deprive them of the opportunity
to
no you deprive them of the motivation
that that necessity often provides
and so you know you said well in
cultures where you're living more hand
to mouth
you you don't have the luxury of
making things unduly complicated and
there is some advantage in
stark motivation you know if you're
really hungry
you don't have a lot of existential
angst around eating
you just eat and
so that that that definitely is a
problem
it isn't obvious to me what to do about
that either is
it it's one of the diseases of of
of wealth what should i do
well i don't have to do anything well
why should i do anything or what calls
to me
that's that's also a problem that's
going to become increasingly
relevant do you ever wish sometimes like
if you could do it again that you got to
be in like a more of a primitive kind of
life where you just like
where things just felt like if you saw
an animal it kind of felt like y'all
maybe knew what each other was thinking
or something like that
like sometimes i feel like i love
being in america and i think it's really
cool but
sometimes i'll see like something a
national geographic or something i'll be
like man that really looks
it looks a lot more real you know like a
lot more visceral like
like i've been to africa before and i
remember looking in the eyes of a man
one time
and it felt like he was like no joke
doctor
it felt like he was like three million
years old
like it just like his eyes it just felt
like man you could just dive into his
eyes and never hit the bottom man you
know i just
do you ever think they get how how neat
it would be maybe to have more of a
primitive type of
i don't know if primitive is right
people people obviously have a nostalgia
for that you know i mean
that's why we camp that's why people
have a cottage in the woods
there is something about about that more
direct existence that
is obviously attractive to us um
it doesn't mean that we're likely to
produce it for ourselves although it is
strange that we'll do that when we're
vacationing
yeah it is strange that we'll like kind
of go back to almost like we'll kind of
flirt with having nothing
kind of yeah and it isn't it isn't
exactly obvious
well and it's also interesting that we
regard that as a break and i think part
of the reason for that look
there isn't a lot of evidence that
people in industrialized societies
are happier than people who are in
non-industrialized societies in fact
the evidence is actually quite the
reverse i would believe that
and i think the reason perhaps not the
reason our reason because there's
usually many reasons for anything
is that it requires constant
it requires a certain amount of constant
deferral of gratification to maintain an
industrialized lifestyle
you're not living in the moment you're
always putting off the moment so that
well so that you'll live longer so i
mean one of the advantages of being in
an industrialized society is that your
life expectancy is much longer
but there is something that's more
primordially satisfying about
or there seems to be about um
a lifestyle where the re the actions and
the rewards and the punishments aren't
so
separated you know you're going to
medical school you're slaving away let's
say
the reward for that is deferred far into
the future
and you're you're giving up all sorts of
momentary pleasures
and there's a cost there's a cost
associated with that as well
now and
it isn't an easy one to well it's the
constant battle
that we have between what's good in the
moment and what's good over the long run
it's a very difficult thing to get right
yeah and our existence here is more
about what's good over the long run
maybe it's a little more like well
that's
yes well at least the culture is built
that way
right right yeah yeah it's built on
deferral of gratification and
and and and so on and so
that makes it kind of insipid in some
ways it isn't as adventurous or exciting
yeah yeah or it doesn't seem that way so
interesting though i mean it seems that
people
who are in less industrialized countries
and have a less industrialized existence
will trade that quite
rapidly for the opportunity to progress
so to speak economically so yeah all
right let me crack in a little liquid
death here
as i hit these ad reads uh
covered spring break is right around the
corner people gonna be running out there
coughing
coughing down your daughter's neck
coughing on your son's back and legs
who knows what's going on spring break
you better tighten up your pants tighten
up your crotch and you know who can help
manscaped
here to ensure that the party in your
pants never stops
even veronica corningstone wouldn't say
no to this pants party
that's a joke from um that movie
look manscaped is dedicated to helping
you level up your body grooming game
i recently got my buttocks waxed and
also tightened up around my crotch
with a special trimmer that does not cut
you
do yourself a favor and always use the
right tools for the job get 20
off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo a lot of free gifts they send you
get 20 off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
t-h-e-o that's 20 off with free shipping
by going to manscape.com
theo say aloha to your new beautiful
hairless body with manscape
fabletics mens that's what you want to
be a
fabletics men's fabletics
represents for every guy who wants to
look and feel his best
without breaking the bank and that's all
guys that's all men's these days
to get the best activewear at the best
prices
get at least 20 to 50 off retail prices
every time you shop go to
t i www.fableticsfabletic s dot com
slash
t h e o for access to an insane deal
deals that are not sane get your first
two pairs of shorts for just twenty four
dollars when you become a fabletics men
vip member at checkout do it
i'm wearing their stuff it's great to
work out in you feel good
that's right all types all colors no
exclusions it's an insane deal
because they know that once you try
their gear you'll be hooked like a fish
go to fabletics.com theo
for access to an insane deal
that includes free shipping that's right
on all orders over 49
and free returns on exchanges within 45
days
support the podcast get athletic where
fabletics
yeah it's interesting also too that you
would think you would find happiness
in in um
not goal scoring but like i noticed in
my own life in the past year since i
spoke to you last you know i've probably
had some
a decent amount of success and life kind
of got a little bit more exciting with
doing some touring and
um you know was more financially
rewarding
and i always but i found that i was
really
not unhappy i was grateful but i was i
guess i was a little unhappy i think i
always felt like when i got to a certain
level of success that
the questions that i had inside of my
heart or inside of my brain or the
the discomfort i felt like everything
would go away like
like life would hand me some like like
magic answer book that had a couple
decent answers in it you know
but i mean like beyond order yeah yes
yes like beyond order
like there would be okay you did it you
know like somebody comes out from behind
the door and they're like all right
bucko you know like finally oz comes out
you know and um
right but it and says good job but that
never happens
no no well you know that's that's
another indication of
of the perverseness of human beings to
some degree so
look there are there are two kinds of
reward technically speaking there's
satisfaction and there's incentive
reward and
satisfaction is the reward that you were
sort of dreaming about it's
it's the so you're hungry and you have
thanksgiving dinner and you're no longer
hungry that's a reward
that's satiation it's satisfying it it
stops you from being hungry
well you think while i'm hungry i don't
want to be hungry anymore but hunger did
give you something to do
and there was the anticipation of the
meal you know and
sometimes on thanksgiving day people
will not eat all day just to heighten
the anticipation right
because that that increases the
incentive reward and
incentive reward is what you experience
when you're moving towards a desired
goal
rather than when you attain it and we do
have this vision it's a
vision of utopia and probably is what
motivates utopian thinking motivates
ideas of the promised land which is milk
and honey
that if we just turn the corner and get
to here
everything will be all right yeah and
that
that isn't the case um
we're wired up so that the pursuit is
often more engaging than the
than the acquisition yeah i wish i had
to realize that though as i was trying
to acquire i didn't
there were it's like it's such a tough
thing i i
missed some of the moments of the
pursuit because i was so focused on i
think on this
end goal that would make any of the
uncomfort or all
it would make all the pain of the the
sacrifice
it would make it all worth it kind of
right right
right well that and that there is some
utility in that sort of dream too
because it
having that image of the future also
motivates you to pursue it
but the problem with that kind of
thinking i suppose too is that
this is dostoyevsky raised this in notes
from underground it's a great short book
and he created short i'll give it a
chance man it's a great book it's a
great but it's really
it's a real punch that book and it
contains a very
powerful critique of the idea of utopia
and dostoevsky's and he was talking
about
the sort of precursors to the russian
communists and their notion
if you just gave everybody enough
material resources that all of a sudden
the problems of the world would
disappear dostoevsky
first of all points out that that's
nonsense because
um for reasons that are similar to the
ones that you laid out but also that
even if it was true people are so
perverse in a sense
we're such peculiar creatures that we
would smash our happiness
all to pieces out of sheer boredom just
so something new and exciting could
happen so that we would have something
to do again and wow i read that and i
thought
wow that's exactly right it's that it's
this
searching that's part of our essential
nature is not only
insatiable but it's actually
desirable because well
what do you do you shake hands with oz
and then you die
it's like done i'm over well you don't
because you want to get on to the next
great adventure and so
it is i you know the sermon on the mount
seems to address this to me
this fundamental problem and my reading
of it anyways is something like
um align yourself with the highest good
that you're capable of imagining
and so for all intents and purposes
that's god the
sum total of all that's good and you
live in relationship to that
and then concentrate on the moment
and see it it seems to me that way you
get to have your cake and eat it too
right because you're aiming at something
that's like the promised land this
proverbial utopia
it's it by definition is the best
possible thing
and maybe your view of that's going to
change as you mature but it doesn't
matter that's still going to orient you
and having that in mind so now you're
pointing in the right direction
you can attend very carefully to the
details of the pursuit
and that's i think that's that's the
best we can do
well i i certainly haven't well i did
come from the sermon on the mount so
hypothetically it's a reliable source
you know but i think it makes a
tremendous amount of sense
psychologically
yeah i mean why would you not aim at the
best that you could conceptualize
if you were going to aim right um and
having done that well then it is
reasonable to concentrate on the present
and then you can then you can immerse
yourself in the present
and enjoy it um
and and then you don't perhaps have
those regrets that you described of
missing the voyage because you were so
focused on on the on the
say the material luxury yeah and
material luxury is a strange thing too
you know i mean
um it isn't obvious often whether you
own something or it owns you
and and i don't mean that in a flippant
sense oh i wouldn't at all recently i
was investing in you know
people doing cryptocurrency now it's
like invisible i don't even know what it
is you know but it's
people are excited by it and i started
to notice
those markets on this crypto thing and
uh and i didn't mean to interrupt you dr
no please go ahead um thanks um
so but i noticed like i'd wake up in the
middle of the night and i would check
this thing
and finally i realized like whatever
monies i'm gonna possibly make in this
portal this gambling portal of
cryptocurrency
um which no judgment on it i don't know
enough about it to really judge it but
i'm spending like important time
checking it i was just i realized i
became a slave to it like
and so i just sold it all i don't want
i just it did i in in my heart and in my
chest it didn't feel good having that
distraction to check all the time
about what was going on with this money
it just felt like it owned me
and um and i immediately decided you
know what i just don't want to be owned
by this
maybe something else but just not this
you know
right and was it specifically the worry
about it that was bothering you or what
what do you think
triggered or or alerted you to the fact
that that pursuit wasn't for you
that's a great question i think it was
um
i couldn't control myself this is the
truth i couldn't control myself from
checking it
and so the only alternative i had was to
eliminate it
because i was really having trouble and
it doesn't fully answer your question
but i was just having trouble stop
checking it so i just said i have to get
rid of it
well it answers it to some degree you
found um
to your surprise see this is partly what
i what we were talking earlier about
not hiding things in the fog this is
part of the process of
coming to a clearer vision of yourself
is noticing exactly that
because your theory was well i can buy
this cryptocurrency
and maybe i'll make some money but
regardless one way or another
this is going to make my life better you
had a theory of yourself and you had a
theory
of the money ah yeah well it turns out
that that was wrong
now why exactly we don't know but
the consequence of that was that you
became a slave to
a set of impulses that you didn't find
enjoyable in the least
yeah and that is and and so then you
stop doing it and
and and and fair enough that seems to be
the right
right solution yeah and that's a kind of
a simple scale i think and
that scale evolves as i get a little bit
older of
does this make me feel good like does it
really make me feel good
like even sometimes making some money
doesn't really make me feel good you
know um
you know like does it make me feel good
as like a human as like a
something that has to be alive do i does
it feel like it like
brightens that part of me that makes me
feel proud you know i guess i
i don't know i'm trying to explain it no
that's a it's a great thing to explain
as far as i'm concerned because
look you said does it make you feel good
and then you started to investigate what
good meant and well both of those things
are really worth doing
they're not foolish in the least because
what's good
you know when you brought in the idea of
being alive which you know you might
think well why did you bring in the idea
of being alive
obviously your life but you're you're
there's a theory there that's emerging
too which is well
i'm a living creature and i'm a well
this african that you saw who was so old
you're that old
you're really old you know life has been
around for three and a half billion
years we're really old and god only
knows what we're up to or who we are
and so you say well we're going to
pursue what's good
and what is that well it has something
to do with
the fact that we're alive we have to
serve our own
biological reality we we have to address
the good in a manner that's that's right
for
for for us as as living creatures and so
you say well we have to pursue the good
but we also have to figure out what
it means what the good means
you know and that's partly what i'm
trying to do in well and beyond order my
other books i
looked a lot at traditional ideas of the
good most of those are
grounded in religious conceptions you
know what does it mean to
to pursue the good what does it mean to
be a good person
well these are very complicated problems
and
and but they're you you don't you don't
get a free pass on them
you if you're if you're murky about them
then while you're you're ill-defined and
vague and inarticulate
in your own life and that's not
there's comfort in that it's comfortable
yeah oh it's very comfortable
it's like a nice very it's like a nice
shawl or something you know it's almost
it's merino wool i mean it's nice you
know it's
really nice to be comfortable and not
have to ask myself
am i happy am i being of service do i
feel like i'm
contributing anything to the world do i
feel like
i'm being honest do i love myself
you know do i love others am i being a
good brother
am i being a good son
if some of the answers aren't what i
want them to be am i trying
in some way to maybe
get to answers that i'm more happy with
um
you know am i proud of myself am i
ashamed of myself
um where does my shame come from
you know yeah well that's a good
question that's a really tricky question
that's when i feel a lot when you
i just feel a lot i feel you know shame
really
it's such a powerful thing sometimes i'm
carrying a shame i don't even know if
it's my own
yes well that's why there's the concept
of original sin
you know the shame is such a universal
human emotion it's
it saturates our existence it's partly
because we're so
social you know and so the sense that we
have a responsibility
to ourselves and to others is really
built into us at a very
very profound level multiple in multiple
ways and
we've we we exist in relationship to
that shame all the time and
it's easy to say well you should
dispense with it
you know and but it's not so easy to do
and it's not even clear
how you should go about dispensing with
it
you know i've seen people in my clinical
practice who had what seemed to be
seem to be counterproductive levels of
shame
right they would do things that someone
else might do and then punish themselves
far more than seemed appropriate and i i
started to think about what does it mean
to punish yourself appropriately
philosophy of punishment which i
outlined to some degree in the first
book
on the chapter on children which is
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them
well you have to stop them well how do
you stop people well you punish them one
way or another even if it's just
withdrawal of attention
there's a so then well how should you
punish assuming there are standards
etc well one rule at least with regards
to yourself is you shouldn't hit
yourself harder than is necessary to
teach you
right so if you've learned your lesson
good enough
and i think that's also often a prefer
condition for forgiving other people
it's like well you know did they learn
their lesson
yes well then maybe you can let it go
because additional punishment
what is it going to make them learn
their less the lesson even more
well why will i forgive myself why will
i forgive other people before i forgive
myself i wonder
well that's a good question because it
isn't obvious that you should right you
you
because you know we tend to think that
people are selfish and
they put themselves first but it's just
as common the reverse
is just as common where they'll be
better to other people than to
themselves
yeah i feel that a lot it isn't yes i i
i think it's more common than the
reverse actually
although people can act selfishly from
time to time
i do think that most people punish
themselves more than they punish other
people
and that's that's also something to be
aware of and to see if you can
regulate that because it's not it's not
necessarily for the best even if it
might be associated with the willingness
to take
responsibility yeah i think it just
comes from having to take a lot of
responsibility growing up and so you
would be hyper
you know you would have to be very stern
on yourself um
but i don't want to get away from shame
because it's really important um
well shame is a good pointer to the good
too
hypothetically because you could ask
yourself um
well why what am i ashamed about what is
shame
what should i do about it those are all
good questions maybe you can dispense
with the shame that's excessive
but if you're ashamed well does that
mean that you did something wrong
well if it does that means that there's
such a thing as doing something wrong
that seems to imply that there's such a
thing as wrong that seems to imply that
there's such a thing as
right and so shame in principle
can also be a pathway to to what is good
say well if i'm engaged in something
that's good
at least i won't be ashamed and that
i mean everybody has to answer these
questions for themselves but
i think that's something that's very
much worth considering what would
what would be the case if you decided to
stop engaging in all those actions that
made you ashamed
yeah yeah no it's good and it's nice to
think that
shame can be a direction and anything
can be a direction that could lead us
then to the reverse
which is like yeah if if something is
wrong then there must be something
that's right and so well it's the best
evidence for some
it's the best evidence that i know of
for for something that's right
right it's it's it you can
you can find people who will debate the
existence of
the the true or the good they're cynical
and they're nihilistic let's say
um they're not naive maybe that's their
advantage
but it's very rare to find someone who
doesn't believe that there's such a
thing as what's wrong
and so and an untrue and so
that's a good starting point it's like
if you want to discover what's right
you can first discover more easily
discover what's wrong
look i think that's partly why we like
anti-heroes in
in movies and in fiction you know what's
the purpose of a dark
character well he shines a light on what
the reverse is
and sometimes that's very powerful in
the batman series for example
the joker generally was
was a better bad character than batman
was a good character
he was more realistic and more thought
provoking
yeah yeah there was more
i want to say more depth there but there
was more depth there there was there was
like
salmon yeah well i think it's partly
because the joker especially heath
ledger's version
was pretty realistically evil
in a psychological sense whereas batman
well he's a he's a
he's a vigilante and
yeah whereas being a vigilante might be
you know one pale reflection of what the
good is because it requires courage and
and and is involved with justice it's
still a pretty pale reflection of what
the good
is so i do sometimes
go ahead sorry doctor no no you you had
a thought i'd like to hear it
i sometimes think maybe that's why it's
almost interesting to be the joker in
the world sometimes to be
to to delve in that turmoil of
the darkness and stuff because it's a
more complex character in some ways
there's almost
some appeal to it well you know
there's a notion derived from the
psychology
psychological theories put forth by carl
jung and
and and he derived some of this from
nietzsche
a philosopher and nietzsche
famously claimed that most morality
was not morality but cowardice it was
merely the fear of getting
caught wow or the or the fear of public
humiliation
something like that that's what keeps
you in line so then if there's a riot
and
there's no police around you're
perfectly happy to throw a rock through
the window because
the probability of getting caught
declines precipitously
so and then if your morality is all
persona so
for jung a morality that was nothing but
conformity and adherence to social norms
and fear
sort of a narrow constrained i'll never
dare to do anything wrong and therefore
i'm good
yeah that wasn't that wasn't good at all
and we have a lot of that these days
yes definitely definitely and so
under those conditions if if you're
nothing but a persona
and so you're an obedient coward let's
say
then your dark side is actually the
pathway to salvation
because it's what breaks out yes
precisely it's what breaks that
that tawdry banal
morality into pieces and leads you
forward
that's crazy so sometimes you need the
dark side to even see what's going on on
the
ah it's tricky it's very it's very
very frequently the case and i mean it's
it's a
it's an axiom of of jungian
psychotherapy that the pathway to
development is through the shadow
so for example um you might have
somebody in your clinical practice who's
um being raised by by extremely
conservative and religious parents
which i'm not criticizing by the way but
you know they're 27 years old and still
a virgin
now look there's utility in
fidelity and promiscuity isn't a plus
but it might be that if you're still a
virgin at the age of 27
that it's necessary for you to
investigate your lust in order to
progress
past your mere childlike obedience
right right yeah because you may have
some hang up there that's even
preventing you from
engaging and getting settled down you
know oh you in all likelihood because
for example if you're terrified of that
then perhaps you're not very good at
sophisticated sexual suggestion like
flirtation and so then you're nowhere
near as attractive as you might be so no
one is going to be
you know interested in you as a
potential mate yeah
you know and it you might also see
someone who
prides themselves for example on never
getting angry maybe they had an
overbearing father who was angry all the
time
i never get angry well that person is
constantly being pushed around by his or
her boss at work and maybe
his wife or husband his or her wife or
husband
and that that i'm too good to be
angry persona is stopping them from
manifesting the aggression necessary to
even tell the truth
about their situation man there's so
there's so many boxes and places we can
put ourselves we have to be careful
everything is kind of a little bit of a
trap sometimes
yeah well that
that's why we pay attention to being
bored i suppose to some degree you know
that's a sign too that
the box has got a little bit too tight
yeah and
then you need to make arrangements with
the part of you that can break things
because
things need to be broken just like they
need to be fixed and something that's
old and
and and and ready to fall down sometimes
needs to be leveled before something new
can come along
look there's nothing more obvious in the
world today than
the fact that you might need help and i
know i know i need help because i get
help
what i'm talking to you about today is
getting help that is better than what
you've been getting you could ask your
boy sidney for some information
and that little bit shall tell you some
or you could ask a little daniel over
there for some information and you know
he's over there he's on he's hitting him
winston's
and he's been locked up in his own
backyard for doing family crime
but better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist real
help we're talking real help
the service is available for clients
worldwide
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
you know i tell a story a while back i
was going to see my friend chris dillio
yeah it's about a year and a half ago
and i was not doing well i was probably
crying and driving and i wasn't even
listening to uh country music
so you know just natural
and i wasn't doing well and i needed
some help so i pulled over on the side
of the road
and i called better help and
in no time i was facetiming with a real
human
female psychotherapist visit their
website and read their testimonials that
are posted daily
go to betterhelp.com theo
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
you can get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
theo this podcast is sponsored by better
help in this past weekend
listeners get 10 off at betterhelp.com
slash
theo if you need some help and you don't
want to go to a
person in you know in your town or
you're scared or whatever
give it a ring bug up your head is a
unique spot
you know and you could do little things
you could do a uh
ear wax cotton handle thing
see what's up you can do other stuff put
other put a hat on your head
comb your hair all those things are
unique but none of them are going to
change your life
wouldn't it be great if they were a
pocket-sized guide
that helped you sleep focus act and be
better
there is and if you have 10 minutes
headspace
can change your life headspace is your
daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app headspace
is the only meditation app advancing the
field of mindfulness
if you're not being mindful you can be
mindful
and that's called headspace you know
there's so many different little uh
meditations on there
it teaches you how to meditate some
people say why
i sit there and you know i don't know
what's going on and i can't relax and i
got ants
suddenly i got ants on me damn
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
six hundred thousand five star reviews
and over 60 million
downloads you deserve to feel happier in
head space
is meditation made simple go to
headspace dot com
slash t-h-e-o
that's headspace.com theo for a free
one month trial one free month of
headspace
with access to headspace full library of
meditations
for every situation everyone that's
right
this is the best deal offered right now
head to headspace.com
theo today you've probably tried
meditation before and it didn't work
or maybe you felt like you were doing it
wrong if mental health
is part of your self-care plan this year
you owe it to yourself to try headspace
and now back to mr peterson so lucky to
have him
you know what one of the things i
learned from reading nietzsche was
again in relationship to morality is
that
um a man for example
someone who is incapable of violence is
not moral because they keep it under
control
right right because they're not doing
that's right they don't have the
capacity it's like well i wouldn't
engage in a fist fight well yeah
right precisely and and i can parade
that as my moral virtue i'm
i'm non-violent i'm non-aggressive and
this is completely independent of the
morality of violence or aggression you
know
i mean obviously we think it's moral in
cases of self-defense and so
it has its necessary place
but you have to ask yourself all the
time is like are you law abiding or are
you just
conventional and cowardly yeah dang
man more questions you got to ask
ourselves we gotta we gotta ask
ourselves questions
i think that's just such a big thing we
have to like people we have to learn to
get into places and
ask ourselves questions and really come
up with some answers
and one thing i notice is the habit of
it gets it helps you fine tune
the practice of it just even the
practice of it helps you fine-tune the
ability to do it
because at first it feels very
impossible when you first start asking
yourself questions to really think
you're going to get somewhere and get
answers
yeah well to begin with you don't
necessarily get you
you don't get going very quickly right
right right
and that's again you have to have some
patience with yourself when you first
take those stumbling steps
you said that since we've talked last
that you know your life has progressed
positively is that the case
yeah yeah yesterday so what to what do
you
to what do you attribute that what have
you been doing right or what have you
been doing wrong
less well one thing that's helped me i
think is just
i've had more exposure to people that
are
more capable in a lot of different
fields than myself
so i think that's made part of me want
to rise to the occasion a little bit
more
not to be equals to them or anything but
just to it's made me a little more
worldly i think in some ways
in other ways my brother made me promise
i would go to therapy
even if i didn't want to so that's made
me have to like
commit to going and speaking to a
therapist every week so that makes me
have to um
just talk about stuff a little more and
i think slowly in some of those moments
i've had to like
you know i've had moments where if i'm
really feeling something
i'll kind of ask myself what am i
feeling right now like am i feeling
sad am i feeling disappointed am i
feeling
dejected am i feeling tired you know
i just start to really kind of like it's
almost like using a metal detector over
my feelings when i ask
questions and then sometimes one of the
words will kind of spark up and like
okay i'm feeling
uh dejected um and then why what
who's making you feel dejected what's
making you feel dejected
it's almost like i'm like sherlock
holmes but
i'm the crime scene yeah
that's perfect that's a that's perfect
well that is exactly that process by
which knowledge emerges that i was
referring to
before it's like you have an emotion but
you don't even necessarily know what it
is
yeah it's just a clue it's like bubbles
that come up in a river or bubbles that
come up in a lake
right and sometimes there's a monster
down there dude and that gets
scary when you start to really get some
of the answers you're like oh my god
and some of them will make me just
sometimes break down crying because
it'll be such a real
unearthing of something that i didn't
know was going on inside of me
yes well that's another reason why
people don't look
is that there's a monster in the depths
and and that metaphor of the bubbles
that's
that's that's a perfect symbolic
representation
the depth because look you can't see
what's in the depth
so the depth is what's unknown and
something lurks in the unknown and
when emotions arise as you mentioned
it's a manifestation of something that's
underneath
you can see this in you see this very
clearly in intimate relationships you
know where
one person will get annoyed at the other
for some minor transgression and soon
they'll be fighting about something that
happened or didn't happen 10 years ago
and then
they'll get to the point where they're
investigating the structure of the
entire relationship
and then that'll stop people from ever
having a dispute at all because they're
so terrified that
any pathway into a dispute will lead
down into
you know is this relationship worthwhile
that's actually part of the reason i
think
that it's useful to have divorce
difficult if not forbidden
because otherwise that question it's
like do you really want to be tortured
by that question for the rest of your
life
at some point it's it's nice to just say
well i'm not going to go there that's
off the table
yeah i um
i want to we talked a little bit about
shame and i wanted to kind of take it
into a different direction and um
you know i feel a lot i've kind of felt
some shame
um like i don't feel ashamed of my
country like i live in the in the united
states
and i don't feel ashamed of my country
but i feel like
more recently there's been
like i'm supposed to feel ashamed of my
country like i know like the olymp
the olympics is going to be coming up
sometime i don't know when but i know it
keeps coming up
and i'm it's like if i cheer for america
it almost feels these days in america
like you're
wrong um and it seems like there's a ton
of animosity and resentment
uh from americans in but who are
enjoying like the comfort and the
privileges
and the the the opportunities of of
america um towards america and towards
like its history and stuff
um but i but like if we didn't have the
battles and we didn't have
like the social revolutions that have
happened in america over time
you know then half of the world would
still be enslaved and
you know there'd be a lot less
opportunity for all types of people and
all types of genders and everything
so it just feels like such a weird time
there's like a lot of shame being cast
on
people in america for
for i think supporting like a
traditional idea of america maybe
yeah i think i think you're dead on with
all those observations and and
especially with regards to the sort of
questioning attitude you have
towards it it's like well look let's see
if we can sort that through a little bit
all right well there's some real
complex existential problems there
because you you pointed out well
with any complicated nation there's
the bloody history and the
accomplishments and the question is well
what do you make of the relationship
between the bloody history and the
accomplishments
and it's complicated so you're you're
cursed and blessed by your history
right and what's the right attitude well
okay let's look at patriotism for a
minute
now in principle pride is a sin
and i think the reason for that's more
like arrogance
and arrogance is a sin because an
arrogant person
is convinced that they're absolutely
right
and that can make you a tyrant to other
people but also to yourself it makes it
very difficult for you to learn
for example and so you might say well
i'm a patriot and you
and then if you're if you criticize that
you could say well that's a sin of pride
and
um look at the bloody history of your
nation and how dare you be proud of that
and and it's not easy to figure out
how to argue your way out of that but by
the same token
to have no affinity for your community
and your country
seems also seems to lead you places that
aren't
particularly good so it seems to me that
um one attitude you could have towards
your country
is gratitude that's not pride exactly
right that's so you could be a patriot
of gratitude
and you could say well look man i go
outside and
hey look there's a highway and there's a
bridge and
there's a school and a university and i
didn't make these things and
i can walk down the street without fear
of like
mass thugs most of the time and
i can pursue what i want
at least compared to people throughout
history
and right a lot of opportunity yeah and
a lot of security
a lot of security i mean the probability
that that a person who isn't involved in
criminal activity is going to be the
victim of a violent crime is extremely
low
so and far more than at any other point
in history
and so i think from animals like animals
used to attack people all the time but
they don't even
that that hardly even happens anymore
here
yes well way back when
this is millions of years ago there was
a cat in africa
that had two large teeth in the front
and one large tooth on the bottom that
exactly
fit over a hominid skull yes
bro yeah right absolutely and it turns
out that we're not eaten by many of
those anymore and
the problem right and you know
we've kind of dealt with the predator
problem to the point where we actually
feel sorry for the predators
you know maybe we want a few more wolves
and a couple of lions and tigers which
is easy to say if they're not eating
your children
at the time but right right so it seems
to me that
you know security we're definitely
secure
we are definite well comparatively
speaking and
for sure you compare us to the rest of
humanity in the past and the rest of
humanity at present
it's like you can be grateful for all
those things and still
so look when you're a kid you kind of
have a naive
patriotism the same way that you have
naive trust
when you're a kid as long as no one's
abused you you kind of trust everybody
and but that's not really trust you know
it's
it's not trust in the sophisticated
sense trust in the sophisticated sense
is more like
look i know that you're as full of
snakes as me
and that if i enter into a relationship
with you there's a possibility of
deceit and betrayal but i'm going to put
an honest foot forward anyways
and take you at your word partly because
that's an encouragement for you to
manifest your best
and hopefully you'll do that with me and
so that's an act of courage that makes
the world
better and you still might get stabbed
in the back for doing it but
you're not a fool under those conditions
you've taken a calculated risk
and i i would say the same thing about
patriotism it's like when you're a kid
you know you're you you you stand up
when the american flag shows and you
sing and
you're you're an unquestioning
participant in that
and then maybe when you're an adolescent
you start to learn about the
sawyer elements of history and that
takes a hit
but then maybe you get beyond that and
you think yes well human history is a
complete bloody nightmare it's a bloody
tragedy
it's a it's a catastrophe but
i'm still look at all the things that
have been produced as a consequence and
you're grateful for that and and that's
a more mature
form of courage i would say rather than
the unthinking patriotism or unthinking
anti-patriotism for that matter it's
discerning gratitude
right and i think you can be
discerningly grateful for what the us
has to offer and if you're not moving
away
that's sort of evidence that you feel
the same way
yeah well sometimes i think a lot of
people would like to move away but
there's just nowhere left to move you
know
i think a lot of people sometimes would
love to start a new country or something
but they just
there's nowhere left to go kind of well
it's good in principle you know
i saw i went to an airbnb out on
vancouver
in the vancouver island vicinity a few
years ago oh there you go on one of
these islands
you tried it but populated by mostly by
hippies
yeah and we came across this
couple who rented this little cabin that
my wife and i stayed in
and they had decided to sort of go back
to the land
well they bought something that owned
them
because they were on this island it was
pretty isolated and
it could be self-sufficient but
do you know how much work it takes to
make you self-sufficient
wow like just keeping yourself in
chickens is no
simple task it's it's a it's a daily
grind
and that's just chickens right and maybe
you're training
eggs and so on yeah that's right it's
and so they were really in trouble this
couple because
they wanted to go start a new country
but they had no idea
just how difficult it is to well to have
a chicken let's say which is something
we take for granted because it's so
unbelievably simple yeah all these
problems are solved for us we don't even
notice
how difficult it was to solve them have
you seen
there's that television show alone that
was actually filmed out on vancouver
island do you ever see any episodes of
that show
no no what's its theme it's they take i
think maybe 10 people and they put them
onto
like an uninhabited place and they have
to survive for themselves by hunting and
fishing and trapping
and so it's kind of reality television
but they the contestants have to film
all the footage themselves so there's no
crew there so
i mean you have people really like
killing aardvarks and ox i mean hunting
down bears it's pretty intense
um it's about as like real
as i've ever seen a show get but the
first two seasons were on
uh vancouver island and it
well it turns out doing things like
hunting and fishing
are actually incredibly difficult
technical skills because
animals don't like to be eaten and
they're actually pretty smart
so you have to know a tremendous amount
before you can manage that with any
degree of success
yeah um so patriotism so
so i if so if we're out of time what do
you think about that i think i mean i
think your comments about
i think the idea of patriotism is under
assault
because you know it's an oppressive
culture and all of that
and there there is an element of that
that of course is true
but i think well i like hearing what you
said to have a gratitude
uh you know to have a thankful gratitude
of where we are and of the place that
i'm in
to think of history in a little bit of a
longer term
instead of just in maybe some of the
simpler terms that maybe i saw in
commercials
um growing up and stuff like that
um and just in some of the simpler terms
of like
saying the pledge of allegiance and
stuff but i
um i really like having the feeling that
everybody is on the same page
even though maybe that's just a uh
a creature comfort that i've had growing
up and maybe that's changing some in
america
um it just used to feel like everyone
was on the same page
yes well that that that brings us back
to the technological revolution to some
degree
you know there does seem to be a certain
amount of fragmentation of the narrative
let's say
and that is unsettling
because it is when everyone's on the
same page
they're not at each other's throats
you know and you might you can put that
down and you can say well that's just
conformity it's like well
first of all let's not get too casually
critical about the idea of conformity i
cover that in chapter one do not
casually
denigrate social institutions or
creative achievement it's like
it's really hard to get everybody on the
same page
and it's really hard to get everybody to
conform especially when they're doing it
voluntarily
and there is not much difference between
that and peace
and if you don't think that that's a
good thing then you should think really
hard about failed states
where no one's on the same page and you
get an instant
proliferation of warring gangs of armed
thugs
and if you think the utopians are going
to win
the armed thug battle you've got another
thing coming yeah because
they'll be the first ones on the
chopping block and so
you know you're you're a comedian and an
open person and
not likely to have a great taste in some
ways for pure conformity and
and i'm someone who enjoys artistic
creation and
and revolutionary ideas but
by the same token i'm not someone who
despises conformity
you know well you said in the book i
mean you said that we're always going to
have as humans we're always going to be
searching for revolutionary ideas it's
something that
um is constantly the way that we've
always been
and it's the way of like just a a
liberal way of thinking is to keep
moving forward and progress and try
things that are new and want to do that
but i just feel like you have to have a
foundation of comfort to be able to do
that from
because some of that is a luxury of
being comfortable
um or at least tremendous amount of
enough um and to feel at all
and when things get really uncomfortable
that feels a lot scarier
place to be creative from almost
well the first thing we should point out
is that
being a conformist isn't the highest of
moral virtues but
being unable to conform is worse
now refusing to conform that's in a
different category you might have valid
reasons for
especially if you're exceptional and you
know you could say well
virtually everyone is exceptional in
some regard
and should perhaps not be conformist
there and we could say fine
but the rest of the 95 percent of them
should
go along with the crowd because that
that's going along with peace and
we also don't ever want to confuse the
inability to conform
with the ability to produce
revolutionary ideas
because just because you can't conform
or are rejected doesn't mean you're a
genius
what it most likely means is that you're
just incapable
and then you're going to be highly
motivated to confuse your incapability
with creativity and that's not
helpful and then you pointed out
something that's also very important um
just how many dimensions do you want to
be exceptional on anyways
you know you're you're a comedian and
you have to take substantial risk to do
that and
it's quite threatening it wouldn't be
such a bad idea if the rest of your life
was
well maybe secure enough to allow you to
tolerate that
yeah yeah to have some more sense of
yeah like um
i guess i worry on like a bigger like
picture as a nation
that like if we start to like if the
fabric of some of the textile of the
past if some of the tapestry kind of i
guess or tapestry
of the past starts to come apart
like i'm all for making new tapestry but
i just feel like
i just get scared i don't know if i feel
but it's more a fear
i get scared that if we do that that
things could just tear and and i just
don't know what's going to happen
i guess i'm just i'm scared a little bit
i don't know
what the future of this country that i
live in looks like
and i used to feel like i had a little
bit better idea
but i don't know if the idea of what i
thought it looked like
was just a comfort
based upon like my skin tone and growing
up with at least
food in my house you know i i you know
some stuff like i just don't know if
i don't know if maybe my idea was just a
luxury or something i i don't know
do you know what i'm kind of saying a
little bit i'm just kidding well i think
that's a question
that's a question that everybody's being
driven to answer
partly because there's intense moral
pressure to ask yourself that question
you know
to what degree was your privilege
unearned well
there's an easy answer to that actually
lots of it
yeah but the same holds true with
virtually everyone else yeah
you know and so um
who's who's got privilege depends a lot
on what group you're willing to use as a
comparison
yeah yeah so um
even impoverished people in in north
america
are rich by world standards yeah
yeah they're in the top one percent
generally speaking
and they're certainly in the top one
percent by historical standards
the problem with with hammering home the
idea of undeserved privilege is that
there's no one who can't be crucified
on that particular cross right right you
know unless you're born naked in the
middle of a field with
nothing yeah everyone is the undeserved
recipient of
of the fruits of the past the fact that
you have a mother is
is a privilege you didn't earn that
and so when you say you deserve nothing
because of your privilege
what makes you so sure you're not saying
that to everyone for all time in which
case no one ever gets anything that they
are that they can have for their own
so it's a very dangerous game well
i don't see where it can end it's not
it's not obvious because
imagine each person is multiple has
multiple identities
that's intersectionality we all have
multiple identities you're privileged
along some of those identities and
relatively speaking and less along
others
so if you're young and black and female
well you're young
right so so that's not
deserved it's not like you earned being
young
and so right how are you gonna be some
way of prayer there's always gonna be
some form of privilege
in every regard yeah i certainly didn't
feel privileged growing up i mean i feel
like a lot of what i've had in my life
has certainly
been earned um i felt disadvantaged in a
lot of ways
um you know emotionally and some there's
always yeah
i think everybody would have their own
uh discussion their own like
not their own parameters but yeah i
could see how everybody would have
pluses and minuses
well that's why i think the right level
of analysis is the individual
you know and when you move away from
that it gets danger it gets dangerous
quickly
and it gets dangerous for everyone and
and the
the reason why is the reason that you
just laid out you take any individual
person
you can point to the advantages that
they had now look
i understand that some people i mean i
was a clinician for a long time
and i saw people who had lives that were
so hard that
you can you could barely even imagine it
you know
i had one client who was
impaired intellectually
she had she lived with an aunt who was
schizophrenic who had an alcoholic
boyfriend who was extremely violent and
also schizophrenic
who used to bother her about being
possessed by satan
she was so um
uh i hate saying shamed ashamed that she
couldn't look
anyone in the eye she would walk down
the street with her hand like this
sort of bowed down because she felt so
um so unworthy
she wasn't an attractive person she
looked like a street person so people
treated her
badly all things considered now look
she i saw her at this hospital that i
was working at
where the inpatients were people who
were in even worse shape
than her they were people so hurt that
they couldn't be de-institutionalized
and i saw her because she had decided
that she wanted to take one of these
institutionalized people for a walk when
she was out walking her dog
so despite all her her catastrophes
which were
plenty you know she could still see
outside of herself
to someone who had it even worse it was
really something
you know yeah well and so this privilege
game it's like
well look to your own privilege
and that isn't i'm i'm not saying that
there
aren't historical injustices but
of course there are many of them right
there are for everyone in a lot of ways
yes but if we only look at the victim
side of things anyway even as a human if
i only see myself as a victim
i'm really going to have a tough time i
can see myself i can respect that i'm a
victim of some things
but if i only see myself as a victim
it's going to make the rest of my life
pretty tough i feel like
well it also enjoys what it matters what
you want to do about
the fact that you're a victim do you
want to take away from other people
you know it isn't that and that
i don't know i kind of put us on a lot
of different planes here at once
oh that's okay well that was a very
complicated problem and it's one that
you know i think is particularly uh
relevant
to your particular country at this
particular time and place because
that the tapestry is under assault and
the thing is it's a lot easier to burn
something up or to cut it up than it is
to knit a new tapestry
it's really hard and has there been
is it is it okay where we are right now
from an outsider's perspective
is it scary like based on like
historical
um civilizations and stuff like
do you think we're in a place that is
like
still kind of safe judging from an
outside like or from a
you know i mean you're still in western
civilization canada's not extremely
different than the us
um do you feel like we're in a scary
place or do you feel like
it's just a lot of pomp and circumstance
and at the root of things we're
were still at a very uh realistic place
i think there are always
dangers that threaten the stability of
societies
i think that those dangers are real but
i think they're always there
i think that i have faith in the
robustness of
say american institutions all things
considered
it seems to me that you your country has
weathered
crises of at least this magnitude and
often far worse many times in the past
and
and that's worked out um
so i think there's reason to be alert
but not hopeless
i mean on the broader scale the broad
scale
world scale let's say it's hard to make
a case that
things were ever better than they are
now
and it's almost impossible to make the
case that there was ever a time in
the past where things were getting
better faster than they are now
so it's reasonable to assume
that everyone on the planet will be out
of abject poverty as defined by the u.n
by the year 2030.
wow it's half well it already have from
2000 to 2012.
and so and that was the fastest
transformation in human history by a
huge margin
yeah i've been seeing less poor people i
feel like honestly
well there there's there's variance
because in the western countries that
the working class hasn't kept up as well
as they were
in the 60s let's say in some ways but
globally speaking there's lots of
reasons for optimism
but it's a difficult problem to settle
because there's always the possibility
that any given problem will get
completely out of hand you know that's
the
the case that people make with regards
to climate change
you know well there's a small percentage
of complete catastro
a small percent probability of complete
catastrophe
well we don't know what to do with a
problem like that
because it's impossible to calculate how
many resources you devote to something
that's absolutely catastrophic but that
has a small probability of occurring
right right you know like what if the
greenland ice sheet
melts right well then the oceans rise
you know multiple feet
and that's a catastrophe well how much
is it worth to stave that off
it's very very difficult to calculate
yeah and plus we're still a lot of
people are still surviving a lot of
i think there's still that a heavy
survival instinct in a lot of people
where
it's more of short-term survival that i
don't even think it's
it's our fault for thinking that way
it's just built into like our limbic
system or a brain stem or something like
it's hard it is yeah it i agree with you
it's an archetypal story that's the
apocalypse
yeah you know the end of the world is
always upon us
you know i well go on sorry doc well
it's because
things can fall apart for us completely
and they do in our own life there's
illness waiting there's death waiting
like we we have a built-in sense that
things can come to a cataclysmic
end and it it and that also makes us
prudent and careful and able to look
at the future and first all catastrophes
but the problem is is that we can also
generate false positives and be unduly
worried about things that are very
unlikely to occur
yeah yeah and sometimes it's like some
people will start to become
unduly worried about things that they
don't even know if they can occur
it that even becomes an addiction for
some people like they're just addicted
to problems you know
like um i noticed that a lot like people
are just addicted to problems um
especially on social media in in in the
us and
and and i had a question about social
media sometimes i feel like tech
is like the new fossil fuel kind of um
like like bandwidth is like the new oil
and like youtube is like the pipelines
and like
um you know like wi-fi is kind of like
this
is this natural gas like it's all kind
of
um i don't know there's like these
platforms that we need to be able to
survive these days
um you mean they've become part of the
infrastructure right they've become
huge parts of the infrastructure
especially in communication
um yes and communication has become one
of the main
uh uh i mean especially even since we
talked last like last time we spoke you
were talking about how
um video and uh podcasting has become
such a new form of communication how
people are using it and
the platforms that we're on are now like
even
probably twice as popular as they were
two years ago when we spoke
um so i sometimes
i find for myself like i get afraid to
kind of speak up and even ask
questions like on so on on my podcast
and
and to talk about certain topics because
i'm afraid of being
um d platform like the platform can be
taken away
and they never i just wonder have they
ever had that in history like in the
past like
you know people you you might you you
might not be afraid to write something
because no one was going to take away
the trees to make the paper
you know um but now it feels like if you
don't
and i may be wrong but i feel sometimes
like if i don't say the right
not say the right thing but if i don't
evade certain conversations
and raise my hand and ask certain
questions that if
that if i do do those things sorry that
they could take away the forest they
could take away the
the paper the youtube the instagram they
can take away the platform
where we basically has become our
english language kind of in a lot of
ways
well you know i mean in societies that
weren't free and that would be most
societies
the probability that your voice could be
taken away was very high because you
could just be killed or imprisoned
wow and i suppose all things considered
it's better to have your youtube channel
shut down than to be
imprisoned or killed right right
it is it is new i suppose in that
we're dependent on these technology
companies increasingly dependent for our
interpersonal communication
i don't feel like the fear that you're
describing is
unwarranted i certainly feel the same
way about my podcast and
youtube channel is i've had guests on
recently
where i've been extremely uncomfortable
talking about the topics that we've been
talking about
and i think reasonably so
you can face de-platforming
or worse they can just shut you down
completely and it's arbitrary and very
very
complicated and costly and hard on you
and
and then there's the constant
probability of
being swarmed on social media
which is in some ways a new phenomenon
partly because of the sheer volume of it
yeah
and the degree of exposure so there are
reasons to tread carefully
that's for sure and it is quite
terrifying
no doubt about it have you run into
trouble with your podcast
no i haven't run into trouble i think a
lot of it for me has just been
fear um you know i had on
uh robert f kennedy who's a friend of
mine and he's
not an anti-vaxxer but he is a lot more
about safe vaccines and making sure that
vaccines have been
tested properly and he's an
environmentalist
you know since he was a child and so it
makes sense that he
you know he cares about the environment
around us and the one that's in our
veins you know going into our bodies
he's just an overall environmentalist
man
but um but i know he was his instagram
was taken away for being
i don't know if he was anti-vaxxed but
certainly for like bringing up a lot of
topics and and questions about
vaccinations
um so i don't know i guess i just see it
happening sometimes and so i just get
i just get worried i just get like um
you know i just wonder has there ever
been a time and place in history but
but i guess you answered it that some
people used to be killed for being
for saying with that oh that was the
norm wanted to say like
free free expression is that's not
common
but do you worry that we're we're like
kind of cornering our
any of our freedom of speech or anything
or am i just just scared
well i worry enough about it so that it
scares me
to talk about certain things and it
isn't obvious to me that that's for the
best
i don't think your fear is unwarranted i
also think that
freedom of speech is sufficiently
threatening so that the probability that
it will be curtailed is always high
and and that we have to what is it the
price of freedom is eternal vigilance i
think i've got that right i don't
remember who i said it but
who said it but
and then so you might think well what
should you talk about and what shouldn't
you
and i think that depends to a large
degree on your conscience
you know if you're interested in
something you're trying to figure it out
if you thwart that then you thwart the
part of yourself that's interested in
things and trying to figure them out
and i can't see that's for the best for
anyone and
i do believe that all things considered
free speech is a lesser evil than
constrained speech because
someone has to decide what the content
of the speech is going to be and
it's i don't see that we should give
that power over to someone
um lightly no matter who they are
partly because things change too just
because something happened to be the
case a year ago doesn't mean that it's
the right solution now
and so we we we have to engage in these
sorts of discussions to keep everything
up to date
you know there's conformity and that's
back to rule one
there's conformity in social
institutions hooray
abide by them but the underlying
environment shifts around
and so sometimes the traditions of the
past are no longer
functional and have to be updated and
the only way we can figure out when
that's going to happen is by
communicating about it and
so you don't want to constrain that
because we all end up out of date and
and paralyzed yeah so
yeah i think there's a feeling of maybe
a fear of like paralyzation or something
i guess it's not as much a reality now
that i think more about it as much as it
is just kind of a fear
um but also a fear to speak up so i
think i just feel afraid to talk about
things sometimes or to even raise my
hand and ask
questions because of things i've seen of
people being
you know you know deep certainly more
like that than
yes it's certainly more like that than
it was ten years ago or twenty years ago
i certainly feel that way much more so
that's
what happens in history when that
happens is that does things usually
like uh work out okay
i guess so because we're here
that's what we hope for i guess it
depends on whether or not we let the
fear stop us
yeah right and if enough people let the
fear stop us then that won't be good
yeah so we'll try not to do that
and hope that suffices yeah i'm gonna
try not to do that
um i had a question about um
so i noticed uh whenever i was young
growing up
like um i was thinking about like my
first kiss when i was growing up you
know when i was a kid and
and um and i noticed as i get older and
get involved with women and
that sometimes i i i feel like i spend
so much time
trying to kind of recreate the initial
moments that i had like in that initial
kiss moment that i had you know
like i remember my first kiss like when
i was moving towards her face i just
remember feeling like
like the ships were crossing the troy
and i remember feeling like
you know like sparta and just like you
know like denzel washington was there
like everything was going on inside of
my body you know it was like every
the whole like you know the like
everything was there you know the
grand canyon was there and everything
was there in this moment like watching
me just
being a part like it was in my skin
waiting to see if i could
land this kiss with this girl and i
think i romanticized sometimes like
moments like that
that's great in my future that i'll
never be able to get back to those
moments you know like um
that was great look like i still chase
that high i still chase that novelty you
know what i'm saying like
even now and no moment now will ever
live up to those initial moments but
sometimes i'm obsessed with the feelings
that were
in the the novelty of
youth and it's like i'm constantly
trying to recreate those and nothing
ever suffices
and so everything sometimes feels like a
little bit of a
exhale yeah well i
i wrote about that in two chapters in in
beyond order in
it's rule eight i believe which is make
one room in your house as be
in your home as beautiful as possible
and
rule 10 which is plan and work
diligently to maintain the romance in
your relationship
and both of them focus
to some degree on the nature of the
experience that you just described
you know there's a certain pristine
um there's a pristine and transcendent
reality to experiences of
of being in love and experiences that
are associated with childhood before
everything becomes stale with repetition
yeah
and part of the question of life is to
how to rekindle that
so that so that you can and it's even
associated with what we were talking
about earlier which is that nostalgia
for more primitive conditions
um i in in rule eight i suggested that
people cultivate a relationship with
beauty
because that is one way of inviting that
that feeling of awe i mean i think you
did such a great
job of describing how significant that
first kiss was you know oh yeah even
tarzan over there
what's that even tarzan was there now
that i think about it
right right well all romance all the
the romantic tropes all the movies focus
on exactly that experience
you know can you recreate that within
the confines of an ongoing relationship
well it takes a tremendous amount of
effort it's not
that's the thing about youth is you get
these gifts right
when you're older you have to work at it
but it's worth working at
and you can you can set up romance in a
permanent relationship that can be
extraordinarily intense if you're
if you want that and if you're willing
to work for it
yeah and it's worth it because otherwise
you abandon it and that's not good and
the same
goes for beauty one of the great things
that artists do
is remind us of what's right in front of
us
because as you get older what you see is
more and more memory and less and less
of the thing itself
and an artist comes along if he's a real
artist just whacks you on the side of
the head and says
no look at it this way and you look at
it that way and you think oh yes
that's now i remember yeah and
yeah i like chapter go ahead sorry and i
haven't gotten to eight and ten i'm
stuck i'm stuck in three
i'm not i didn't mean to be but there's
a lot of big word you gotta be it's a
time
it takes a little time hey no problem um
um i like chapter 8 i think better than
any of the other chapters because
it does concentrate on this experience
of of youth and
and the the ability to be immersed
so completely that's characteristic of
childhood and
and does there's an idea you know that
the kingdom of heaven is
something that's already inhabited by
children
right unless you become as little
children you'll know you'll know in no
wise enter the kingdom of heaven and
that is a it's a poetic echo of the fact
that those experiences are possible but
with effort and discipline and aim
you can reduplicate them at least to
some degree in your adult life and
that's definitely worth
that that can be worth the effort
especially if you find yourself
longing for it yeah yeah a lot of i mean
even i remember
after our last conversation a lot of
things come down to effort really
and really living um you know
uh effortly living
you know because living after a while it
becomes sometimes especially in this
in in in our country that you're kind of
floating in a
you know in a little bit of a cushy
river kind of you know so i think yeah
if you really want to
live if you really want to challenge
your soul and get into whatever's in you
or or experience anything
experience some things more than
the gratis that is kind of like
cloaked on us each day in america then
you have to really make an effort um
one of the things i noticed in that's
relevant to that
um i think you
need a meaning to sustain you in life
because life is difficult and so the
meaning has to be proportional to the
difficulty i think everyone knows that
and
wants that um
whenever i talk to audiences about that
and pointed out that
it's through the adoption of
responsibility that you're most likely
to encounter those meanings
the audiences would generally go silent
because that isn't an equation that's
often made
right is that well you need meaning
that's better than happiness
happiness is a consequence i would say a
fortunate consequence of the pursuit of
something deeply meaningful but
almost everything that's deeply
meaningful requires
the willingness to adopt responsibility
and so that's a good thing to know
because
you might ask yourself well why should i
adopt responsibility and the answer to
that seems to be something like
wow well it it deepens your life because
i want meaning i want something more
no it's a great because i think a lot of
us are swimming around
thinking that something meaningful will
show up there's so many there's so much
advertising and so much
this is important this means something
this is valuable
and a lot of it is um is pyrite man it's
pyrite
um do you remember your first kiss dr
peterson was it in canada
yes it was certainly in canada my man
i remember the first time i held hands
with my
the woman who became my wife wow were
you guys outdoors or indoors
it was high school graduation and she
had been a friend of mine but that was
our first
date and that was an unparalleled thrill
i would say so but i was able to
duplicate that many times in our
marriage thank god with her
cooperation and participation it was
something we really concentrated on
making time for romance once you get
married
romance sort of becomes number 11 on a
list of 10
um necessities you know it's still up
there but it gets pushed out by
everyday concerns work and domestic
responsibilities and children and all of
that
um you have to force it back up into the
top three or four and
you know that also stabilizes your
relationship across time and is good for
your kids and good for you
so that's that's worth
that's worth the work and it's really
useful to know that it is work
you need it is work it's not just going
to happen and the fact that it isn't
happening for you
it doesn't mean that there's something
wrong with you it just means that
it's it's work you you have to aim at it
you have to aim at it do you remember if
you kind of did you reach for your wife
saying or did she make that first
initial move do you remember no
yes i do remember actually she took my
hand
that's cool man she was much more
confident in that regard at that time
than me and probably still now for that
matter
i know you speak a lot about your
granddaughter in your book
like not a ton but there's a couple
moments so far that i've noticed where
you kind of reference her or watching a
child grow
um and some things that they learn what
is that your first grandchild that you
have now
yes i have another one now i have two
but she was the first
how um has it changed any of your views
of being like alive or the importance of
family or just maybe just any of your
do you notice anything different in your
heart or your brain
obviously there's going to be some stuff
in your heart that's obvious but
has any of your it's mostly cemented
home the
notion i had that there's there's really
nothing
in the final analysis there's
there's your there's the car your career
and your family
you know and your family is half your
life
or more and
i don't know what you do when you're old
if you don't have grandchildren
you know i mean it's not like they
occupy all my time but
it it would be it'd be such a hole there
yeah oh i can imagine yeah sitting there
by yourself and just doing solitaire
maybe or something you know
well and not being able to interact with
children
yeah because children are revitalizing
as well as being exhausting and
frustrating in all of those things but
but they are revitalizing and they're
like fire you know if if you put a
two-year-old among a group of 75
year olds the 75 year olds don't do
anything but watch the two-year-old
they're fascinated by by the child and
to see all that new potential coming to
manifest itself
i mean those are the sorts of things
that cultures tell you you know
get married stick together well why well
it's for the children but that's to your
benefit as well and then it's for the
grandchildren because that's to your
benefit as well it's a
it's a good long-term solution
even though it's very difficult and
requires all sorts of sacrifice and but
you lose that and you get all fractured
up and it isn't obvious to me what
what you do then when as you age
so it's made me more aware even of the
of the great privilege of
having a family that loves you
and how valuable that is above
everything else
yeah that's powerful man it's uh i can
imagine i don't have that yet but
sometimes i feel myself like
i constantly kind of feel myself coming
to some of the same
like i'm in a cul-de-sac and i think
sometimes it's what i'm looking for is
probably a family of my own you know i'm
actually i've had fear about kind of
taking some of those next steps but i
think
some of what i am looking for is just
more a sense of like this is my
tribe or this is my group or this is
i don't know something i can feel it
kind of um
yeah well if you didn't people who felt
that had children and that's how we're
all here
so yeah yeah it's a
it's a huge part it's a huge part of
life and it gets a bad rap
it's a responsibility wrap again it's
like well you know
can you really be with one person for
the rest of your life and
is that realistic now that people live
so long and well i don't know if it's
realistic or if you can be with one
person for the rest of your life but
there are definite coming up with a
better alternative is no
simple matter and it's a
blessing to have young people around
that care whether you're alive
you know as you get older and so
i wouldn't i don't think it's a good
idea to deny yourself that
that's been a real gift yes well and you
should you know
[Music]
this chapter about romance in
relationships might be particularly
useful to you if you're thinking about
having a family because
i do believe that it's possible to keep
that romantic
vision alive you have to make it a name
like you have to really work at it you
think well what do i want how would i
like to have a date with my wife
well what would you like to see her wear
how would you like to arrange the music
you know
all of these things people are afraid to
attend to them
but if you attend to them you can get
good at it and then you can make
something magical and
then the magic that you can create with
the same person over and over stops you
from being frustrated that
it's the same person because yes
so and i think you need to know that
that's possible
yeah yeah man i think sometimes we just
don't hear that kind of stuff enough you
know
no i don't remind her i know we don't
remind
um all right one more question i wanted
to ask you this was about
uh you know i've i've been in recovery
for like five years i guess and i've
struggled recently in the past year
during the pandemic um
but i'm still a strong believer in
recovery and in the 12 steps of recovery
um why do you feel like the 12 steps of
recovery or the 12 steps work
well for so many people and
do you think that that's the best
modality to uh
to obtain sobriety for um for
for addicts well it isn't obvious that
there's a good alternative
so that's the first thing if aaa
doesn't work it isn't like there's a
preferable treatment
most people cease alcohol use
on their own without medical
intervention we don't know why although
religious transformation
seems to be one and of course the 12
steps capitalizes on that
i think that it's quite an intelligent
program psychologically speaking you
know
first of all you have to make a moral
inventory you have to figure out
what's wrong in your life which would
obviously include the alcohol misuse
you have to rectify that take
responsibility for it try to try to
chart out a new course
also provided with a social structure
which is really useful when you're
trying to stop drinking because it's all
very probable that most of your friends
are going to be
drinkers and so that leaves not only do
you stop drinking but you stop
associating with your friends or maybe
even with your family members
that's really hard yeah so you know an
aaa
doesn't seem to be an exploitative
organization
it's all volunteers um
as and speaking strictly clinically
there it isn't obvious that there's a
better alternative if you were being
strictly scientific you'd say well
there's never been controlled trials of
a
a where you randomly assign people to
the aaa group
and to the non-aa group or another
treatment to see head to head which
works better
and there's the problem that many people
drop out and so you can't tell exactly
what the success rate is but
but that's it in some sense a technical
argument
um it also isn't clear to me that aa
does people harm
right right which is also really
important because
many medical treatments can produce harm
and so the worst you could say is well
maybe it won't work
um so yeah and that's not that big of a
risk
especially already comparatively
speaking
yes yeah if you're already all sick or
something you know even
or so what do you think
what do you think it was that enabled
you to stop drinking
like why did you manage it what did you
use
as an alternative well i noticed when i
went well my problem was cocaine
but i worried that if i drank i would do
cocaine i never had a problem
drinking but i was worried that one
could lead to the other
yes undoubtedly i think well
one thing it gave me a place where i
realized that
other people were sharing their thoughts
and feelings and i'd never been in that
kind of environment before
and so to so that was one of the big
things was the emotional sobriety
um and then it helped me having a
relationship with a higher power which
i'd never really had
right and what difference did that make
do you think
man that made it was the first time in
my life i
i really i i felt like something cared
about me unconditionally
and you experienced that oh and i
experienced at a level that shook me man
like i've got electrocuted like it was
yeah that a god just that this invi that
some invisible
thing cared about me at a level that i
could never even imagine
and that no matter if i was good or bad
or if i did something
naughty or nice or cinnamon or spice man
that this thing loved me
and that was uh i just never felt that
before so
for there to be a way to get to that
feeling that's what made
recovery feel like important to me i
think
yeah well to have an experience like
that is a real gift yeah
it was just it was powerful um
dr peterson i don't want to take up a
ton of your time man but i just
i think once again it just reminded me
that life is a program of effort
you know um and if we want to see
changes and if we want to
experience something different than the
circle or the even the
the figure eight that we're in or even
the trapezoid that we're in that we have
to
that we gotta uh we gotta
make an effort you know we really gotta
make it good talking to you
like it was last time appreciate it very
much you too jordan thank you so much
for your time and uh congrats on the new
book and i look forward to finishing it
and um you look great
congratulations on your continued
success you too brother i'll chat soon
all right all right cheers good talking
with you thank you now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel
i'm falling like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want so thin that they're damn
they're gone my gum